oh
[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here so
nowadays it seems like it's never quite
enough to just nail all the pillars of a
great smartphone and put it out
it seems like not only do you have to do
all of that but you have to take one of
them and push it to the absolute extreme
the maximum and so this is what it looks
like when you nail all the pillars of a
great smartphone and then take one of
them and take it to the next level this
is the huawei
p20 pro so this is one of those phones
you've either heard a lot about recently
or never heard of definitely two camps
with this one this is not coming to the
us
and usually that stops me from even
trying a phone in the first place
because i know i can't recommend it for
a lot of people
but this caught my attention obviously
like huawei phones in general have just
been getting my attention more and more
lately
but this one just captured it completely
it's crazy new color triple cameras on
the back 4 000 milliamp hour battery 109
score on dxomark
so i picked it up i used it here's my
thoughts so on the outside aesthetics
wise i do like this phone a lot it has a
couple flaws it's not perfect but it's
one of the few really unique looking
phones out there of course mainly
because of this back this gradient color
i mean it's a crazy looking awesome back
of the phone it blends from like this
aqua green to blue to purple and in
different amounts depending on where you
look at it from it looks different in
everyone's video i'm kind of trying to
do my best with the camera i have but
there's other colors of the p20 and p20
pro i wouldn't even consider them this
is definitely the coolest looking one
it's called twilight it's just weird
that there's a lot of text on the back
of the phone i would think it would look
way cleaner if all that wasn't here
it might even look sick with like a logo
tossed on there but it wouldn't be the
end of the world
this just is what it is it's a super
unique colorful
and also fingerprint and dust magnet
phone i got your power button and your
volume rocker on the same side i know
that doesn't count as a colored power
button huawei i know you have a little
bar there but you have to have the whole
button with some color good try though
but the rest of this body is prime it's
what you'd expect from a high-end 2018
flagship which it is so metal rails
curved edges it's ip67 water resistant
which is always nice it's definitely not
too thin you know feels solid in the
hand nice weight it has an ir blaster
which not every phone does now but also
no expandable storage and no headphone
jack this camera bump is also mildly
annoying to me because it sticks out
enough from the phone that it will rock
on a table i just i gotta point that out
not all phones have that problem but
it's not a deal breaker either but
really design wise my biggest question
mark is on the front of this phone
uh so it has a notch so a notch is what
you do in a phone in 2018 when you want
to get rid of all the bezels but you
don't quite have the technology to fully
do so so you know the front-facing
speaker the selfie camera you got to
keep them just make a little cut out
around them fine i get it but this phone
also has a fingerprint reader on the
front and then a huge empty
chin bezel with nothing else in it no
buttons
just a bezel like
you're either trying to get rid of the
bezel or you're not it's weird that they
would put a notch like they're trying to
go totally bezel-less but then also have
a chin
kind of make up your mind there i feel
like you could have made this look way
better with an even top and bottom bezel
there's even an option in the software
to do exactly that and it doesn't look
that bad but yeah the fingerprint reader
is on the front it's still super fast i
don't mind it being here huawei does
that maybe better than anyone still and
it also acts as a gesture pad if you
want to disable the on-screen buttons
and get some extra screen real estate
back you can do that too your call
but above it all is that pretty nice 6.1
inch oled display with of course that
notch that we talked about it's a 2240
by 1080 panel so it's a 18.7 by nine
aspect ratio slightly taller than the
normal tall but the oled panel itself is
pretty good it gets bright enough to see
outdoors with no problem there's no
shift issues it's just not quite to the
greatness level of like a samsung phone
it's not quite as bright or as vibrant
but it's right in line with what you'd
expect from a flagship oh and then it
also packs in a 4 000 milliamp hour
battery in a phone that's not that thick
so that's pretty great this has been
consistently five plus hours of screen
on time which for my use is excellent so
there's no problem with battery here and
i've been preaching like if you want to
make a phone make it as thick as you
want no one really wants the phone to be
that razor thin and adding a couple
extra millimeters for a sizeable battery
is a great choice i mean look at that
this phone is definitely not thick at
all bravo to huawei definitely keep
doing that so for the hardware look it's
it's all pretty damn good the specs
inside
pretty good you know we're looking at
six gigs of ram 128 gigs of storage the
chipset is all right we definitely have
better things out here
with qualcomm but it's still good enough
and the experience of using this phone
again it'll come down to what you do
with android i won't talk too long about
emui but those of you familiar with
huawei know that this is their skin on
top of android here
with this one it's emui 8.1 based on top
of android 8.1 so using it every day i
gave it a shot again and it the more i
use it the more it kind of reminds me of
what samsung felt like a couple years
ago or they're just basically throwing
as many features as possible at you
because really there are a lot of
features in here whether you use them
all or not you know there's backup and
restore features there's big screen
features multitasking features there's
multiple power save modes with different
intensities you can adjust the screen
resolution which is in battery settings
for some reason instead of display
settings uh there's even a smart
screenshot feature that won't stop
interrupting me even though i've turned
it off it still randomly thinks some of
my swipes and knocks are screenshot
attempts and starts doing this magic
animation please stop doing that
overall you can fix or not use pretty
much any of the things you don't like
except for the visual changes i've been
using it with nova launcher as you can
tell but yeah they're still going to
have huawei's icons and huawei's quick
settings and their multitasking ui and
all that
and also you're going to be waiting for
a couple apps like instagram for example
to play nice with that notch android p
when it gets released is supposed to
help a lot with that but for now there's
definitely some bugs but all right all
right i'm sure you knew when you saw
this phone came out with a 40 megapixel
main camera you knew it would grab my
attention
you know why i'm here you knew when you
put out a phone with not one not two but
three cameras on the back that it would
turn my head
you know why i'm here and you knew when
this thing got a dxo mark score of a
hundred and nine that i just couldn't
resist
picking it up and actually seeing what
it's all about
so let's take a deep look at why i was
even interested in this phone in the
first place the cameras so yes the
huawei p20 pro has three cameras on the
back the main sensor is a 40 megapixel
sensor with optical stabilization and an
f 1.8 aperture the secondary is a 20
megapixel monochrome sensor also with
optical image stabilization and an f 1.6
aperture and the third is an 8 megapixel
3x telephoto lens again stabilized this
time f 2.4 so that's a lot of numbers uh
the 40 megapixel sensor is huge and i
don't just mean like the megapixel count
is huge i mean the actual physical size
of the sensor it's a one over 1.7 inch
sensor diagonally that's about twice the
size of the galaxy s9 and the pixel 2
and the iphone 10 sensors that's
half an inch diagonally
damn there are a lot of potential
advantages to a physically larger sensor
i use in my main shooting a camera with
a massive sensor you get better low
light sensitivity bigger pixels better
overall performance less gain a wider
field of view
so i love the concept i love the idea of
putting a big sensor in a smartphone
camera so how'd it turn out well right
off the bat the photos look pretty good
not only is it a big sensor it is a good
sensor so you get accurate colors a nice
dynamic range plenty of detail and
that's really the main characteristic
you're going to notice about the p20 pro
photos lots of detail thanks to the
sensor and the sharpening being
aggressive as hell and then a
shallow-ish depth of field thanks to the
sensor size and the fixed wide aperture
but here's some notes for you to
consider about these cameras besides
just pointing and shooting in auto mode
so number one the main camera uses a
quad bayer structure when taking photos
which means it's a 40 megapixel sensor
but it's outputting data binned in two
by two blocks of pixels so you're
getting an output image of 10 megapixel
images still super sharp and detailed
but 10 megapixel photos number two the
video mode is really not that great some
might say trash like it can shoot
stabilize 1080p video with decent color
and detail
but because of the chip it's using it
can't keep up with the stabilization of
4k the 4k video really looks bad off of
this phone sadly i wish it was as
complete of a video camera as it was a
photo camera but it's not but number
three this whole camera is just fast the
whole experience of taking photos of it
is fast which i love it has laser
autofocus it's super quick the time to
open the camera and actually grab a shot
is super snappy and you can even double
press volume down to take a snapshot of
what you're pointing at in like .3
seconds but then you don't really know
like what you're taking a picture of so
that's maybe a little extreme but the
point is it's fast once you're in the
app you hit the telephoto zoom button
you get 3x or 5x with a single touch it
all works for me and then ai
okay i there's a lot of people keep
asking about the ai all over this phone
but especially in the camera about you
know why don't people give it enough
credit in the videos it's a big deal it
makes better than
others i'll tell you exactly why i've
used it it's pretty straightforward
basically there's a trigger to turn on
ai and the camera it's on by default and
when it's on if you give it a second in
the viewfinder it tries to identify
everything you take a photo of and then
automatically enhance some predetermined
things it thinks you'll like about that
photo and it's right about identifying
what you're trying to take a photo of
more often than not like you take a
photo of the sky it puts it in blue sky
mode take a picture of greenery puts it
in greenery mode flower mode pet mode
everything it just it knows pretty much
instantly but then it's the improvements
that it decides to make once it knows
what you're taking a photo of
that are pretty basic like in greenery
mode for example if you're taking a
photo of a plant and it has green in it
it turns on greenery mode and it just
basically blasts the green channel in
the plants and makes it look more green
cool in blue sky mode it does the same
thing if you point it at like a skyline
and there's blue in the sky it knows
it's blue sky and it just blasts the
blue channel makes the sky really blue
like i
cool that's i'm glad it worked but maybe
i don't even want that to be more blue i
just want a picture of what i'm taking a
picture of i don't know maybe i'm not
the normal smartphone photo taker but i
don't want
automatic enhancement has never been my
thing i i turned it off pretty quick i
usually just want to take a photo
straight from the sensor which looks
pretty good and maybe use that ai later
for like sorting through my photos or
making them easier to find but yeah a
lot of the p20 pro's photos you know
they don't need any editing or enhancing
because they look great straight off the
sensor i mean i'm talking effortless
shallow depth of field
a plus detail like i said from all those
megapixels i just wish the processing
wasn't so aggressive sometimes it looks
a little too sharp
such a big sensor should also have a
great advantage in low light but when
you compare it to smaller sensor cameras
like i did the low light photos are
cleaner yes but they also have a ton of
smoothing and noise reduction because
the processing is so aggressive it
almost feels like the software is
holding back the hardware so when i'm
comparing like these two and i'm after
the absolute best smartphone camera
the pixel is taking often much better
photos more consistently because of the
software i mean there's definitely still
things p20 pro can do that pixel can't
especially with that 3x telephoto zoom
that can be really great
but if what you're after is the best
overall smartphone photos
the answer is still pixel 2 and i think
anyone who shot with both of these would
agree so at the end of the day p20 pro
is my favorite huawei phone yet
obviously no doubt it's kind of a bummer
that is not coming to the us it would be
cool to see i'm still a fan of a lot of
the choices they've made here design
wise build quality wise and i gotta say
even emui is better than it's ever been
but it's not quite enough to convince me
to switch to it full time if the camera
and the software and the build are the
biggest draws to this phone
it's definitely going to have the build
beat i mean this is a one-of-a-kind like
back of a phone for sure but if the
camera and software are both better on
another phone it's remarkable how many
times i keep going back to pixel 2 but
for now i'll give p20 pro like a
45 degree thumbs up pretty good not bad
i'm a fan of the decisions and i'm
looking forward to p30 until the next
one thanks for watching
talk to you guys later
peace